believe it or not
you're in the middle of the kalahari
desert
in a place that is home to some of the
most diverse wildlife on the planet
here you can move among them
they watch you
they listen to you
and they can smell you
welcome to the okavango delta
this incredible wildlife co-exists
within a balanced ecosystem
protecting it has created a
conservation-based tourism economy for
botswana
[Music]
but this oasis is supplied by water that
comes from angola through a wider system
that's under threat
climate change
deforestation
and commercial agriculture upstream are
putting it at risk
national geographic and de beers are
working together in a partnership with
local communities to help protect it
developing livelihood opportunities so
local communities earn more income from
eco-tourism and raising awareness of
this unique wonder so it can be
protected forever
by visiting the okavango delta and
supporting the people here
you can help too
hire an expert local guide to walk
amongst elephants and learn more about
how they shape the landscape
through a locally run operator to
experience the delta in a traditional
boat led by an expert polar
or to fully immerse yourself
book a night under the stars for the
communities of the delta
it was surely be an experience you will
never forget
together we can help ensure that this
lush paradise
along with the people and wildlife who
live here can thrive for generations to
come
you